I'm Justin and this is Tom we are
bringing you your GameSpot news update
and the thing that we're talking about
today is that the playstation is
claiming to have outsold the Xbox one in
January almost two to one nearly double
we're gonna overreact about this the
system's have run out two months three
months now and I think it's clear that
the ps4 has won at this point and
Microsoft should sell off their Xbox
division they'll call it quits join
forces with Nintendo at a tea party and
that's it because what is the point of
even competing really no reason to go on
anymore
yeah but everybody buying seriously um
they have to have some kind of reaction
to this coming soon because really
there's there's nothing that you can say
to that when you're being outsold nearly
two-to-one in one of the biggest regions
where these consoles are sold and we
haven't even sold in Japan yet that's
gonna be happening later this month
yeah and that's generally a sony held
area yeah you're not microsoft's not
gonna be able to make up ground
even with titanfall when it costs so
much more money so it seems I mean I
expect before e3 we're gonna see that
price cut and until then I think that
you're just gonna see Sony pile on the
units because it's it's $400 oh I think
it just it makes sense and this is
something that I know a lot of you guys
are gonna want to comment on please feel
free to let us know your thoughts in the
comments below be sure to follow us on
Facebook and Twitter for all of your
gaming news needs